merci nous sommes de retour sur le
plateau de la voie est libre pour le
débat consacré à l' yonne à l'occasion
des départementales des 22 et 29 mars
avec nos cinq invités andré villiers
pour lui des lits jean-baptiste lemoyne
pour l'ump généraux de nouveau le front
national
jarden paul parti socialiste et chantal
doukha pour europe ecologie les verts et
le front de gauche en l'occurrence et
puis en partenariat avec l'yonne
républicaine
il aime on va évoquer si si vous le
voulez bien la prochaine bataille pour
la présidence du conseil général andré
villiers vous aviez soufflé à l'ump
jean-marie rolland en 2011 le siège de
président vous avez déjà annoncés vous
solliciterez un nouveau la présidence du
conseil général jean baptiste lemoyne
est-ce que vous aussi vous allez vous
porter candidat à la présidence partant
d je crois que vous vouliez commenté la
montée du front national et là vous nous
entraîner sur un terrain robin politique
politicienne justement alors que c'est
pas le sujet le sujet le sujet en
réalité c'est quels sont les dossiers
sur lesquels on va plancher ensemble
quelles sont les orientations et c'est
ma petite personne n' importe peu en
réalité alors échappé que lorsque andré
villiers devenu sénateur remplacement
d'henri de raincourt effectivement il
s'était porté candidat dans la foulée la
présidence du conseil général est-ce que
je dois suivre dans tout ce qui fait un
jeu mais un point d'interrogation je
crois que en réalité la question c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas quand elle est
président c'est l'histoire d'avoir un
exécutif fort mobilisés on va avoir
énormément de deux nouvelles femmes de
nouvelles de nouveaux hommes il va y
avoir énormément de sang neuf je crois
que la question qui aura au sein de la
majorité départementale sera elle sera
plus large elle sera comment on met en
place et jean baptiste j'avais les
ivryens ses fils il ya des candidats
diverses dans différents cantons il y à
des candidats 10 et des candidats
à deux ou trois cantons près tout ça
s'est fait de façon dont vous êtes tous
derrière son corps vous
mais je dire on a tous nos nuances et je
crois que ce qui sera important à
l'issue de ce scrutin et je souhaite
qu'un maximum de nos candidats
l'emportent au premier puis au 2e tour
et bien c'est qu'on ait une majorité qui
soit équilibrée où chacun puisse prendre
sa place et où tout le monde puisse être
pris en compte à l'heure actuelle on a
ce n'était pas possible et on danse et 3
prévus trois premiers vice présidents
qui sont de la même famille politique il
faut sûrement rééquilibrer tout cela
m'est donc tout ça fera l'objet je pense
de discussion et surtout moi encore une
fois un impératif c'est efficacité comme
en fait pour être efficace parce que si
on n'est pas au rendez-vous de
l'efficacité et donc d'une gouvernance
en tout cas dans ses fonctions dit là
qu'est ce que vous nous dites
aujourd'hui j'ai
écouté je suis pas élu déjà donc je suis
ton a déjà je tombe le faire élire pour
savoir si vous êtes ce que voudront les
uns ou les autres un ordre ine vous
sentez majorité vraiment uni derrière
vous dans le cas alors je ne vais pas
vous suivre sur votre introduction
lorsque vous dit que andré villiers ravi
la présidence à l'ump c'était c'était
moins un sujet politique qu'un sujet
personnel je veux le rappeler pour que
les choses soient bien claires
l'opposition entre deux personnes et
s'il n'y avait eu que nos deux personnes
je veux dire je ne serais pas là vous en
parler aujourd'hui c'est qu'une majorité
en tous cas pour les mêmes réserves pour
les mêmes raisons qui n'étaient pas
politiques eh bien on conduit en tout
cas à s'agréger autour de ma personne et
à faire que 2011 voir l'émergence
effectivement d'une nouvelle tête à la
tête de l'exécutif départemental
donc ça c'est une rectification le
deuxième sujet je rejoins jean baptiste
lemoyne qui dit qu'il faut d'abord
passer effectivement par la case
élection soyons modestes alors
effectivement si j'ai manifesté le désir
d'être candidat à ma succession c'est
parce qu'un certain nombre de dossiers
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure sont
engagés en termes de gestion du
département et puis il ya de grands
dossiers qui s'ouvre à nous on n'a pas
parlé du dossier thd on n'a pas parlé de
la couverture santé d'une et l'emploi à
parler de tout mais oui mais en fait ils
sont ces dossiers là qui vont nous
animer demain autour desquels d'ailleurs
la majorité ira bien au-delà des limites
ump et udi et faudrait surtout pas
circonscrire le développement du
département à deux familles politiques
parce que c'est l'intérêt de l'ensemble
du département à gauche à commencer par
où elle a notamment demandé la parole
oui dis pas non parce qu'on a du mal
aussi à suivre le raisonnement parfum
d'europe écologie les verts dans ce cas
précis je voulais réagir quand même à ce
qu'il vienne se dire que ce sera votre
seule réponse de cette deuxième partie
madame du cac alors les chevaux donc on
peut je ne peux pas parler là dessus
mais si vous allez le noir est bon c'est
sûr s'il ya bien sûr le moine je résiste
à gagner qui aura beaucoup de femmes
dans la prochaine assemblée de souligner
que là je suis la seule sur ce plateau
ce qui est quand même la manif est la
manifestation de notre attachement à la
parité et je dois saluer au moins cet
aspect du nouveau scrutin c'est qu'il
impose la parité je ne peux pas en dire
autant du reste
de l'organisation et des discussions qui
n'ont pas eu lieu pour pour préparer ces
nouvelles élections pour vos électeurs
ils comprennent bien votre stratégie de
fanyé ici au front de gauche alors vous
êtes avec le ps au conseil régional
bah écoutez il ya aussi le front de
gauche au conseil régional dans la même
majorité voilà donc c'est pas tout à
fait quelque chose de nouveau je ne sais
pas s'ils comprennent les électeurs
n'ont pas encore voté donc on va bien
voir s'ils comprennent mais enfin je
pense que il ya effectivement des
explications à simple et peut-être qu'on
va y revenir dans une minute sur
l'impopularité de l'exécutif et de la
danse à lyon j'ai demandé à monsieur de
l'or
bah écoutez je crois que c'est pas le
sujet aujourd'hui
pour les électeurs ça peut l'être il
suffit d'un il suffit d'un événement
dramatique d'un attentat pour voir le
président de la république remonter dans
les sondages ce qu'on peut ne pas
souhaiter quand même je sais bien rampe
après un mois après il redescend il
faudra je pense qu'on peut pas mener une
politique en fonction des sondages en
fonction des événements le président de
la république aujourd'hui mène une
politique qui est discutée effectivement
et avec avec des des progrès qui ont été
réalisés notamment dans le domaine
social de la solidarité à l'école il ya
beaucoup plus d'enseignants il ya plus
de gendarmes parliez de sécurité tout à
l'heure il ya des efforts qui sont venus
chez moi je voudrais revenir quand même
sur les sur l'exécutif voix est
passionné on arrive
c'est un peu dommage parce que vous vous
anticipez déjà pour dire que ce sera la
droite qui va être élu ce sont les
électeurs qui désirent quand même mais
bon moi j'attends avec impatience le
troisième tour effectivement puisque il
y aura une petite agitation dans les
coulisses entre l'ump et l'udf
peut-être
c'est le journaliste qui parle allez
vous avez conclure maintenant chacun
cette émission j'ai quand même répondre
sur le 3ème tour
tout humour et la bataille de
chiffonniers qui se prépare et
finalement on va voir que les
concitoyens vont totalement être mis de
côté tout le monde pas seulement les
élus que ce soit de droite ou de gauche
vont lutter uniquement la présidence
nous au front national ou ton pour les
concitoyens nous allons les défendre et
non pas pour acquérir des postes voilà
mais pour les formuler des propositions
un président si vous n'avez pas la
majorité de combat déjà vous en savez
rien on verra mais c'est la fiancée et
on fait confiance aux icaunais pour dans
un maximum de vente de canton élire des
candidats bleu marine allez vous à les
conclure cette émission dans un an que
nous avons désigné par tirage au sort
juste avant le début de ce débat et
c'est vous jean baptiste lemoyne qui
avait été désigné pour vous exprimer le
premier on vous écoute et bien écoutez
moi je souhaite que les icaunais fasse
confiance à tous ces candidats qui comme
justement paul antoine de carvi la cense
valérie logé à auxerre
xavier courtois wallon et bien vont
porter un message de renouvellement un
message de fraîcheur et qui veulent
promouvoir l'excellence pour pour
l'yonne l'excellent ça veut dire quoi
c'est pas être une belle endormie c'est
regarder ce qui se fait ailleurs chez
nos voisins dans le loiret comment il se
développe comme on peut s'arrimer à
cette île de france qui est un potentiel
économique considérable pour créer des
emplois chez nous et puis répondre à des
thématiques comme le très haut débit il
faut qu'on mette les bouchées doubles
comme effectivement la pénurie médicale
autant de sujets que je travaille
naturellement au sénat mais qui demande
une implication concrète ici dans le
temps gameiro dole vous avez voici
quarante cinq mois oui j'aimerais dire
aux icaunais 0 aux icaunais que ce
scrutin est majeur extrêmement important
voilà on le constate avec la réforme
territoriale l'ump comme le ps ont
finalement fracturée et et supprimer
notre département autonome avant le
supprimer donc et ont vidé nos campagnes
de tout des services publics notamment
des gendarmeries et ont livré nos
campagnes et nos zones rurales à
l'insécurité à l'immigration qui grandit
voilà on l'a vu notamment pouilly en
auxois
en côte d'or mais ça peut arriver
également dans l'yonne ce que je veux
dire c'est que pour lutter contre la
fracture territoriale pour protéger le
département pour protéger les habitants
il faut voter bleu marine il faut voter
pour les candidats du front national
merci je n'ai eu 12 jarre de l'homme
pour votre conclusion oui dans une
situation difficile telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui rien ne serait pire qu'un
exécutif en quête de popularité je crois
qu'il faut se focaliser sur les projets
plutôt que sur ces élections personnel
dans l'yonne ont fait avec la xi de la
politique autrement puisque en
partageant des valeurs mais en
rassemblant autour de nous des gens qui
défendent aussi les territoires ruraux
nos candidats ne se bat pas pour des
bastions simplement mais pour des
projets pour des projets pour le
territoire et pour son attractivité
parce que on l'a souligné il ya quand
même un manque d'attractivité dans ce
territoire et pour la solidarité entre
les villes et les campagnes c'est un
véritable enjeu nous sommes les seuls
aujourd'hui au niveau de la xi et de
l'eau candidats à porter un projet
collectif cohérent qui ciblent des
priorités on n'a pas le temps de les
exprimer mais on les a abordées tout à
l'heure en grande partie on a prouvé
qu'on savait faire en pratiquant
d'esprit d'ouverture c'est vrai au
niveau de la collectivité par exemple la
communauté de communes à valence on
travaille en équipe autour de projets
merci madame chantal locat à votre
conclure oui alors nous nous souhaitons
qu'il y ait une véritable rupture avec
une politique dont on l'a vu tout à
l'heure et qui a été parfois opaques qui
a aussi consisté quelquefois à engager
des fonds publics dans des projets
contestable je parlerai par exemple du
soutien de deux millions 4
alagi au centre de formation de l'aja à
une subvention de 650 mille euros ou un
peu moins à l'aéroport de branches ça
ça équilibre bien la fraude du rsa je
crois dont il a été question tout à
l'heure je crois qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on engage le département dans une
politique à long terme dans des
investissements à long terme et en
particulier dans la transition
énergétique parce que c'est elle qui va
susciter des emplois locaux qui est
excellente et vertueuse pour la
préservation de nos ressources et pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
est un enjeu majeur pour toutes les
collectivités aujourd'hui il faut
développer véritablement un soutien et
le maintien des services publics dans
l'ensemble du territoire et c'est à ça
que s'attacheront s'ils sont élus les
candidats de l'alternative citoyenne
sociale écologique et solidaire que je
représente qui ont passé un accord sur
18 cantons des départements et qui sont
soutenus par le front de gauche et
europe écologie les verts merci madame
blue car andré guigné images envie de
dire qui a deux styles qui s'opposent il
ya l'anaphore du président de la
république noah président me président
me président et puis le discours
d'investiture du président kennedy qui a
indiqué qu' on devait s'interroger
plutôt que de savoir ce que votre pays
peut faire pour vous eh bien posez vous
la question savoir ce que vous pouvez
faire pour lui donc je souhaite que
l'ensemble des élus puis s'en inspirer
et que la dcri billy's la
décrédibilisation par don de la parole
publique
dans à travers un certain nombre
d'affaires qui occupe de la gauche et la
droite est bien sont de nature à nourrir
le populisme mais c'est partout il faut
y réfléchir c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut baisser les bras donc je réaffirme
à la fois la nécessité d'offrir une
gestion proximité de défense des
territoires à destination de ceux qui
sont qui se sentent en tout cas oublié
je veux réaffirmer mon soutien nous
équipes de la majorité départementale
assuré qu' un certain nombre de services
comme les transports ferroviaires
continueront d'être présents sur le
territoire et je terminerai puisque j'ai
commencé par une citation par une
citation lé de rené char qui a fréquenté
vaise les picasso un pont impose ta
chance serre ton bonheur et va vers ton
risque à te regarder ils s'habitueront
merci eh bien on arrive au terme de
cette émission merci à tous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci vilain
merci à l'yonne républicaine je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
bourgogne point france 3 point fr la
semaine prochaine nous vous proposerons
le troisième des quatre débats que nous
consacrons à ces élections
départementales de squeeze en côte-d'or
n'oubliez pas l'émission commence à 11h
et d'ici là bien sûr tous les soirs nous
parlerons à partir de lundi des
élections départementales dans vos jt
régionaux est toujours dans les pages de
l'yonne républicaine évidemment tout de
suite le 12/13 poursuivi avec le
développement de l'actualité nationale
et internationale très bel après-midi
actrice merci
votre
les